Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
So, over at YouTube.com/100days,
I'm in the midsts of
a health and fitness journey
with my best friend, Chris.
Hold up -- did I just say
I'm on a journey?
Hank, I'm becoming a self-help book.
Speaking of which, I have long
been an avowed enemy
of the motivational quote.
You know, like
"Tough times don't last,
but tough people do."
Or "Nothing worth having
comes easy,"
or "What's the point of being alive
if you don't at least try
to do something remarkable?"
Which is actually a quote from my book,
𝘈𝘯 𝘈𝘣𝘶𝘯𝘥𝘢𝘯𝘤𝘦 𝘰𝘧 𝘒𝘢𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘪𝘯𝘦𝘴,
so my bad.
My first problem with motivational quotes
is that, like, they aren't true.
Like, tough people don't last.
Like all people, they die.
And many things that are
worth having come easily.
Like bananas, for instance, are
available at almost any supermarket
for like 50 cents.
Also, hopefully, the characters
in 𝘈𝘯 𝘈𝘣𝘶𝘯𝘥𝘢𝘯𝘤𝘦 𝘰𝘧 𝘒𝘢𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘪𝘯𝘦𝘴
spend that novel learning
that an unremarkable life
can be fulfilling and meaningful.
Then there's that old Walt Disney line
"If you can dream it, you can do it,"
which has appeared on more posters
than Justin Beiber's face
despite being manifestly untrue.
Like, have you ever
even had a dream?
I once had a dream I was a Tuatara.
And if the mountain we must conquer
exists within ourselves,
then why did you climb all those
actual, physical mountains,
sir Edmund Hillary?
You should have been
at home, meditating,
conquering the mountain
within yourself.
Also, just for the record, neither
Walt Disney nor Sir Edmund Hillary
ever said those quotes that are
so often attributed to them.
The motivational quote plague
is perhaps most notable
at workout facilities,
like the gym where Chris and I
usually work out has
this Steve Prefontaine quote
about how giving less than your best
is sacrificing your gift.
And a boxing gym we visited had
a hand-written sign reading --
You don't have to get ready
if you stay ready.
I find these little aphorisms,
not just annoying,
but kind of insulting. . .
and yet. . .
Not to brag or anything, but
I ran 9 miles yesterday,
and around mile 4,
I found myself thinking --
you don't have to get ready,
if you stay ready.
God help me, Hank.
I've become a fan
of motivational quotes.
I'm on a frickin' journey.
I kind of feel like my whole
adult life has been
a series of circumstances
that force me to reckon seriously
with stuff I once easily dismissed.
Like I remember living in New York in 2007
and railing against the sheeple
buying houses in the Midwest.
And now I'm a homeowner in Indianapolis
and I quite like it.
I used to think that bestselling
books were, by definition, crap,
and then I found myself quickly backtracking
when I unexpectedly
became the author of one.
I've ridiculed parents for focusing
on their kids instead of the world's kids,
only to become a parent and
understand that impulse,
and I've said that popular music was dead
only to really like Beyonce's album, "Lemonade."
But even now I still haven't learned
that when I want to roll my eyes,
I should probably be alive
to the possibility
that the object of my disdain is
more complex than I'm imagining.
And so, now yes I've become a person
who revels in clichéd,
usually miss-attributed quotes in order to
motivate me toward physical fitness.
This is a surprise on several levels,
not least because I have long
dismissed physical fitness
as a waste of energy, when all that
really matters about humans is their minds.
But these past few weeks have already taught me
that there is no hard line between
the body and the brain,
that running can be good for my writing,
and writing good for my running.
I kind of thought I would have to
abandon like my real work for 100 days
while I focused on my physical health,
but, instead, I'm finding myself enjoying writing
more than I have in years.
And even though I'm spending
more time working out,
weirdly, I find that I have
more time for writing, too.
These days, I'm at the keyboard
pretty much every day.
Because, you know,
you don't have to get ready,
if you stay ready.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
End screen.
Four things. I will be at VidCon Europe
in Amsterdam in April
with many other YouTubers.
Hope to see you there.
Check out 100 days.
I also wanted to let you know
that these 10th anniversary
VlogBrothers woodcuts
are available for a couple
more weeks at DFTBA.com,
and, lastly, Rosianna's self-care bunny
wants you to know. . .
that you are enough.